bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce vendredi de fortes
pluies ont provoqué des inondations en
corse-du-sud et principalement à ajaccio
le bulletin d'alerté orange a été levée
mais il est tombé en 24 heures
l'équivalent d'un mois de précipitations
les intempéries qui ont touché la savoie
l'isère et l'alsace également deux
policiers ont été suspendus après des
faits qui se sont déroulés en dehors de
leur service l'un d'entre eux a fait
usage de son arme
et cela alors qu'il était ivre lors
d'une rixe dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi à paris trois jeunes ont été
blessés par balles
une enquête a été ouverte de nombreuses
réactions après la décision du tribunal
de lille qui a annulé le mariage d'une
jeune femme qui avait menti sur sa
virginité
une question qui est au coeur des
préoccupations de nombreux jeunes filles
musulmanes
elle s'interroge que faire en parler ou
pas certaines d'entre elles vous le
verrez n'hésite pas à avoir recours à la
chirurgie j moins 15 pour le bac les
élèves se préparent à chacun sa méthode
mais ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
utiliser internet comme outil de
révision des cours et des conseils en
ligne
tout cela est bien pratique mais pas
magique reportage à suivre
enfin coup de projecteur la fin de ce
journal sur la villa médicis à rome
la course pour occuper sa direction est
ouverte nous verrons pourquoi ce haut
lieu culturel français suscite autant de
convoitises
merci d'être avec nous on commence ce
soir par les intempéries de fortes
pluies se sont donc abattue sur
plusieurs régions du pays
en alsace les pompiers ont été débordés
d'appels et un affaissement de terrain
sur l'autoroute a4 provoque actuellement
d'importantes perturbations de
circulation autour de strasbourg des
pluies et des innovations qui ont
également touché la région rhône alpes
et c'est encore ce que la situation
était la plus soudaine
ainsi cette nuit la ville d'ajaccio a
connu des précipitations records deux
autels envahies par les eaux ont dû être
évacuées
frédéric cros tard
les corses n'avaient pas dû cela depuis
ajaccio a reçu en 24 heures quatre fois
plus de pluie quand à moi un mètre
cinquante d'eau à certains endroits un
record dans les hôtels situés à l'ouest
de la ville sur la route des
sanguinaires
les clients ont eu à peine le temps de
récupérer leurs affaires
l'espace d'un quart d'heure on avait
quasiment mettre dans les chambres donc
il a fallu précipité a eu plusieurs
personnes pour laisser sortir les
personnes qui t'aime plus âgés qui
voulait absolument son bilan à faire
donc il a fallu essayer de bloquer les
portes ouvertes pour faire sortir tout
le monde
au total ce sont près de 180 personnes
qui ont été évacuées et mises à l'abri
en plein centre ville d'ajaccio
la brusque montée des eaux a nécessité
l'intervention de plusieurs équipes de
secours avec notamment des plongeurs et
dans la nuit pour venir en renfort donc
je peux pas vous dire de nom de blessé
grave je pense pas donc évacuer les
habitants
voilà quelques personnes dans les
voitures et des incarcérations plus au
sud
d'autres zones comme celle de sartène et
de propriano ont été également touchées
par les inondations
certains commerces ont été détruits et
une route nationale a été coupée pendant
plusieurs heures
un coup dur pour les corses quelques
semaines avant le lancement de la saison
touristique
ce soir l'alerté orange a été levée mais
il va falloir entreprendre de nombreux
travaux pour redonner à lille son vrai
visage
voilà pour les intempéries où en est-on
du conflit concernant le prix du gazole
plusieurs opérations escargot ont été
organisées par les chauffeurs routiers
dans plusieurs villes du pays aux abords
de la capitale mais également à limoges
marseille ou encore grenoble
du côté des pêcheurs la mobilisation
demeure également notamment à
montpellier plusieurs raffineries reste
bloqué en france cependant aujourd'hui
deux des principaux ports bloqués ceux
de lorient et du guilvinec ont voté la
reprise du travail ont fait le point
avec arnaud comté gabriel camilla
l'orage gronde sur le port de lorient
mais depuis midi la fronde des pêcheurs
est terminée ces jeunes matelots se
prépare à repartir en mer lundi au
[ __ ] que mon accident et 60 pour soir
qu'il voulait repartir et 40 hurler
continuer pour les chaînes qui s'est on
bosse et on l'en peuvent fait gagner un
petit
mais arrivé en septembre divers là où
ses moyens on arrivera ici personne
n'est convaincu mais après huit jours de
grève les marins ne vois pas d'autre
solution que de reprendre le travail et
on peut pas se permettre de rester trop
longtemps à terre là de la mairie quatre
semaines depuis novembre mais c'est en
euros par an vers son côté de coeur on
sait très bien que c'est ce qui nous a
été promis n'est pas là dans quinze
jours dans trois semaines ou dans un
mois on sera stoppée de nous voir c'est
mathématique sur les quais du deuxième
port de pêche français l'activité
redémarre progressivement 60 tonnes de
poissons viennent de débarquer les
va-et-vient des chariots s'accélère et
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour le
personnage du pauvre donc on vous
écrasez le oui
en bretagne les principaux ports de
pêche ne sont plus bloquées mais en
croire les marins leur colère n'est pas
apaisé les marins pêcheurs depuis
plusieurs jours évoque cercle
l'augmentation du prix du gazole mais
aussi plus généralement leurs conditions
de travail voyons ce soir justement à
quoi ressemble la vie sur un chalutier
le cap fréhel est basé à roscoff là-bas
le mouvement de grève dure depuis quinze
jours mais les équipes de 13h15 le
samedi était monté à bord il ya quelques
semaines pour découvrir ce quotidien
éprouvant reportage romain potocki
c'est l'heure de remonter le chalut
on sortir un chalut de l'eau dans un
ascenseur de dix étages devenu fou est
une partition exigeante
une fausse note et c'est l'accident
bon
merde
non c'est pénible c'est fatiguant on
encore la nuit
dans kung à se reposer mais on n'arrive
pas à se reposer normalement
donc c'est surtout fatigant
comme c'est fatigant j'ai pas que tu as
quelque chose à faire passer le cap
difficile
voilà sega
cédric hui il est tombé à la mer
et il n'était pas remonté sur un bateau
depuis
c'est parce que c'est que
celui-ci prochaine et matinée s'est mis
à bouger chez suis partial avec
lui semble
une offense et elles vont et qui
viennent
drop est là
bichard montée anonymat
des bouts de poisson le fond en est
couvert après chaque pêche l'équipage et
viscères et rip mieux vide et mieux
laver un bourricot ou une lotte se
vendront plus cher à la criée sur le cap
fréhel comme sur presque tous les
bateaux français les marins et claude le
mécano son veiller à la part en fonction
de ce qu'ils pêchent
2 par pour le patron une pour le simple
matelot pour une marée d'une semaine si
la pêche est bonne a marre un peu touché
1000 euros
le salaire cède à se motiver pour faire
les trois huit en un jour c'est d'avis
vre sans plus savoir quelle nuit on est
et ça justifie bien des risques mais
cette sphère menaces ou de chant et
grand huit heures
en une semaine le cap fréhel a filé son
chalut 40 fois par le fond de la mer lui
à main
et la remontée 8 tonnes de poissons
voilà long
une bonne pêche pour la saison mais
gasoil cher oblige la part du matelot
est tombée à 700 euros
une part qui aujourd'hui encore ne cesse
de diminuer dans l'actualité également
cette affaire dans laquelle trois jeunes
ont été blessés par balles dans la nuit
de mercredi à jeudi à paris en pleine
rue dans le 10e arrondissement à
l'origine de tout cela une altercation
entre ces jeunes et deux policier qui
n'était pas en service aussi apparemment
sortait d'une soirée arrosée
l'un d'eux a sorti son arme et a tiré à
plusieurs reprises aurélia guillemin et
christophe kenck l'altercation a eu lieu
dans cette rue animée du 10e
arrondissement après leur service
deux policiers font la tournée des bars
il est deux heures du matin sérieusement
éméchée ils s'en prennent à un groupe de
jeunes gens présents devant cette
boutique de musique c'est qu'il bosse
ici
c'est qu'il bosse ici on croit et c'est
des fous ou quoi on ne va pas calculer
le 10 mai qu'il a commencé à fait faire
cela commence à sortir son on a une
voiture arrive la situation dégénère
je passe la vie je le regarde comme ça
il m'a mis là m'a dit tu sais qu'ils y
ait qu penser qu'il est positif et le
bossu crime je dis moi je réponds par là
j'arrive même plus à parler je suis
sortie de l'autre côté au moment où on
court et ça a commencé à tirer
c'est là que mon ami et c'est aussi une
balle qui ne rentrait pas là des sorties
de votre côté sept coups de feu sont
tirés
trois jeunes hommes connus des services
de police sont blessés par balles touché
au dos
l'un d'eux a été hospitalisé les deux
brigadiers dont l'un a été blessé à la
mâchoire ont été classés en garde à vue
agent service régional des transports
ils sont suspendus de leurs fonctions
le comportement au moins de celui des
deux fonctionnaires de police qui s'est
servi de son arme monde qu'il avait
apparemment l enquête le précisera
totalement oublié les conditions dans
lesquelles ils pouvaient faire une seule
tasse
les deux policiers ont été entendus par
l'inspection générale des services qui
doit établir les circonstances de
l'altercation
l'un des trois jeunes blessés risquent
aussi des poursuites pour coups et
blessures est en marche cette affaire
c'est la question la détention d'armes
en dehors des heures de service par les
policiers qui est à nouveau soulevé les
syndicats ont souhaité rappeler
aujourd'hui que les policiers étaient en
droit de garder leurs armes sous
certaines conditions
car ils sont considérés comme étant
toujours susceptible d'intervenir
24 heures sur 24 audrey goutard
marie-caze aux entraînements dans un
centre de tir de la police nationale
plusieurs fois par an des fonctionnaires
viennent ici pour pratiquer se forme et
quelle que soit leur ancienneté dans la
police les instructeurs sont là pour
leur rappeler la règle la mise en
sécurité et la réintégration
la difficulté pour le fonceur de police
va être de faire de l'analyse de la
situation que se passe-t-il et tout de
suite le vrai question est ce le droit
d'intervenir un choix dicté par la
légitime défense
la règle à laquelle est soumis chaque
policier il a le droit de sortir son
arme que si sa vie ou celle d'autrui est
menacée et ne tire qu'en dernière
extrémité une loi stricte pour des
hommes qui portent leurs armes
même en dehors des heures de travail mes
collègues peuvent transporter leurs
armes de service et l'utiliser en cas de
légitime défense
même hors service par contre il est vrai
que le transport de l'armée ne doit pas
créer un état de dangerosité et c'est
parfois le cas régulièrement des
incidents se produisent comme il ya
quatre mois dans ce restaurant de
franconville une fête trop arrosée un
fonctionnaire sort son arme pour
s'amuser et touchent mortellement un
serveur après cette bavure le patron de
la police a adressé un rappel à la loi à
l'ensemble de ses hommes en revanche
l'hypothèse d'une interdiction du port
d'armes
en dehors des heures de service est pour
l'instant exclue par le ministère de
l'intérieur
en vendée un enfant et ce soit entre la
vie et la mort et son histoire est
extrêmement mystérieuse on ne connaît ni
son nom ni son âge il a été découvert ce
matin flottant dans l'eau du lac
d'apremont
et cela alors qu'aucune disparition
d'enfant n'a été signalée dans la région
reportage sur place
annie épais et alain darrigrand un
visage mais pas d'identité
ce garçon aux cheveux blonds et toujours
dans un état critique à l'hôpital de
nantes
son corps a été retrouvé dans ce lac tôt
ce matin par un promeneur
le garçon au pyjama était inconscient se
trouvait à peu près six mètres de la
berge
en position allongée sur le dos les bras
en croix et il était en position de
force toute la journée les gendarmes ont
cherché en vain des indices sur les
berges dans le lac
mais rien est pas d'enfants signalés
disparus on sait simplement que le
garçon âgés de 7 à 13 ans n'aurait pas
été maltraité ce soir encore toutes les
pistes sont étudiées toutes les
hypothèses peuvent être envisagées de la
thèse du suicide de l'accident de la
fugue de la thèse criminelle
quelqu'un lui jeté le corps dans l'eau -
l'enfant dans l'eau rien rien n'est
privilégiée et tant que nous n'aurons
pas l'identité de la victime
nous pourrons pas privilégier telle ou
telle piste
les gendarmes espèrent toujours
recueillir des témoignages
mais dans cette zone touristique la
présence de vacanciers étrangers
compliquer encore un peu plus
l'identification du garçon et ce sur la
gendarmerie lance un appel à témoins si
vous avez des informations vous pouvez
composer le 02 51 45 19 00 les réactions
se multiplient au lendemain de la
décision du tribunal de grande instance
de lille d'annuler un mariage au motif
que l'épousé avait menti sur sa
virginité réactions politiques à l'ump
on réclame un recours de la chancellerie
le parti socialiste parle d'une décision
atterrante il faut savoir que sur les
forums et les blogs médicaux de plus en
plus de jeunes filles d'origine
musulmane font part de leur désarroi
la perte de leur virginité les paralyse
certaines d'entre elles franchissent
même le pas et choisissent d'avoir
recours à la chirurgie c'est le grand
format de ce soir il est signé nathalie
sa peña et valérie lucas cette jeune
femme va se faire opérer une
reconstruction de l'hymen elle veut
paraître vierge pour son mariage
l'intervention chirurgicale est simple
elle va durer moins de 30 minutes sous
anesthésie locale
la jeune femme repartira chez elle
quelques heures après dans cette
clinique cossue de chirurgie esthétique
il y a deux à quatre ans construction du
maine par semaine c'est le docteur marc
abécassis qui pratiquent ces opérations
a dit
refaire une membrane qui n'existe plus à
partir de ce qui reste
on va essayer de la reprendre de
récupérer et de les futurs et bien sûr
de faire fusionner ensemble pour qu'il y
ait de la même façon une membrane qui
est une très très fine c'est encore plus
fin que la peau la demande pour ses
interventions et forte de plus en plus
fort les raisons invoquées respecter la
tradition la religion qui exige que les
pouces soit vierge à son mariage
il faut que je suis d'origine maghrébine
oui donc c'est vrai que si je veux le
faire c'est pour ma famille pour mon
futur mari
vu que nous on est éduqué d'une manière
à ce que la fille soit intacte
hamon au jour du mariage donc pour moi
c'est important et c'est un [ __ ] moi
je veux une détresse qui alimente un
marché très lucratif
la plupart des cliniques privées propos
ces opérations internet fourmille d
adresses même l'hôpital public pratiquer
réfection du maine et tarifs s'envolent
de 50 à 2500 euros
l'annulation par le tribunal de lille
d'un mariage pour nom virginité inquiète
certains gynécologues qui craignent une
recrudescence des demandes
c'est un rêve y aura forcément plus de
demandes puisque la non seulement ça
passe sur la place publique c'est à dire
et un juge français donnent raison au à
une telle demande
le débat dépasse largement les salles
d'opération où les tribunaux c'est le
statut de la femme qui est aujourd'hui
ébranlée et parmi les réactions
aujourd'hui à sa décision judiciaire nul
en cette union pour cause de virginité
la secrétaire d'état à la ville fadela
amara a dénoncé je cite une vraie fatwa
contre l'émancipation des femmes fin de
citation une information toujours
pratique je vous rappelle que vous avez
jusqu'à ce soir minuit pour poster votre
déclaration de revenus si vous préférez
internet vous avez alors jusqu'à la mi
juin selon les zones
vous étiez près de 7 millions et demi de
contribuer à avoir utilisé cette méthode
l'an dernier à un mois du début de la
présidence française de l'union le
couple exécutif poursuit son marathon
visite des capitales européennes au
programme aujourd'hui pour le président
de la république l'autriche et pour le
premier ministre
l'estonie et la finlande retour sur ces
visites express avec michaël darmon pour
la présidence française une seule voie
mais il faut s'y mettre à deux tandis
que françois fillon traverse à toute
vitesse l'estonie la finlande
nicolas sarkozy lui passent quelques
heures en autriche
ils se répartissent les pays en fonction
des affinités mais aussi en fonction des
petites courses à régler entre collègues
dans les longues nuits de négociations
je dois dire que je suis en tête avec le
premier ministre autrichien je lui
devais beaucoup de cigares parce que lui
n'oublie jamais ses cigares et
franchement ça a été désagréable que ça
soit françois pignon qui viennent lui
apporter les cigares du doigt dix états
visités pour nicolas sarkozy contre 12
pour le chef du gouvernement c'est le
tour d'europe en plus de 80 jours les
partenaires européens craignent ils
présidence française trop personnalisée
alors c'est le sage françois fillon qui
rassure avec le sobre propos nous
attachons avec le président de la
république française beaucoup
d'importance à visiter chaque état
membre pour présenter les priorités de
notre présidence mais surtout pour
dialoguer ensemble un dialogue parfois
difficile car bruxelles a mis la france
sous surveillance
alors quand la commission bout de l'idée
française de plafonner la tva sur les
produits pétroliers
nicolas sarkozy en pologne met les
points sur les i
j'entends qu'elle soit étudiée avant que
d'être rejeté voilà et vous aurez noté
que des quelqu'un propose une idée
en europe c'est le scepticisme qui
d'abord l'emportent à j -30 les deux
responsables de l'exécutif savent qu'une
partie importante du quinquennat va se
jouer quant à nicolas sarkozy déjà sur
tous les fronts il s'apprête à cumuler
deux présidences à sa manière c'est à
dire en appuyant sur l'accélérateur
près de deux ans après le début de
l'enquêté judiciaire l'ancien
coprésident de eads noël forgeard a été
mis en examen pour délit d'initié il
était placé sous contrôle judiciaire une
caution d'un million d'euros a été fixé
seize autres dirigeants du groupe
aéronautique européen sont toujours
soupçonné dans ce dossier revenons ce
soir sur l'origine de cette enquête
judiciaire avec romain mi6 et emmanuel
bec 35 heures de garde à vue et
d'interrogatoires face aux juges de la
brigade financière au final une mise en
examen
noël forgeard accusé de délit d'initiés
est ressorti libre cette nuit sous
contrôle judiciaire l'ancien coprésident
de eads réaffirme par la voix de son
avocat son innocence sera à nouveau
entendu à plusieurs reprises et je suis
convaincu que nous parviendrons à
montreux magistrat instructeur que en
définitive il n'a pas commis le délit
d'initié qu'on lui reproche
nous avons de très bons éléments pour
noël forgeard soupçonnés de s'être
enrichis personnellement grâce à des
informations confidentielles
en mars 2006 le patron de ads vent pour
4,3 millions d'euros d'actions
trois mois plus tard airbus annonce
officiellement des retards dans la
fabrication de l'a380 et le titre
s'effondre depuis le début de la sphère
noël forgeard ni le délit d'initié
affirme n'avoir jamais eu connaissance
des retards du géant des airs et accuse
les allemands d'avoir caché la réalité
se sont mis très en retard tant qu'ils
ont essayé espérait plutôt surmonter ces
retards ils ont rien dit et quand ils
ont dit quelque chose c'est trop tard
cette mise en examen dont noël forgeard
et la première dans l'affairé eads
certainement pas la dernière
en tout 17 dirigeants sont mises en
cause par l'autorité des marchés
financiers et devrait être entendu par
les juges
parmi eux l'allemand tom enders ici à
gauche
l'actuel patron d'airbus on pensait que
les relations franco chinoises et est en
voie d'amélioration mais ce soir le
ministère des affaires étrangères
français réclament quelques explications
aux autorités chinoises la nouvelle
pomme de discorde
ce sont des informations faisant état de
consignes données à des agences de
voyage à pékin de bannir la france de
leurs brochures
vrai ou faux samah soula et tristan le
bras ont vérifié l'information sur place
à pékin
la consigne a été donnée par téléphone
aux voyagistes de pékin en retirer la
france de leur catalogue et supprimer
cette étape du circuit en europe qui a
donné l'ordre
est-il vraiment ferme gêne et confusion
régnait aujourd'hui dans les agences
pékinoise certaines nous ont affirmé que
la directive venait de la municipalité
de pékin qui a pourtant démenti ce tour
opérateur spécialiste de l'europe a
suspendu tous ses voyages en france sans
état d'âme
même si c'est une des destinations
préférées des chinois 700 milles s'ils
sont rendus l'an dernier
c'est vraiment une initiative
personnelle personne ne m'a demandé
d'arrêter les voyages en france
j'ai simplement écouter mes sentiments
de chinois blessé par l'attitude des
français
j'ai changé l'offre de mes catalogues
cependant montré ce que je pense
j'envoie après les manifestations anti
françaises liées au passage chaotique de
la flamme olympique à paris
on pensait les relations
franco-chinoises quelque peu apprise et
notamment après l'envoi d'émissaires
français en chine
ce nouveau rebondissement a pris les
autorités françaises de cours
paris attend des éclaircissements vous
savez sans doute qu environ 500 mille
chinois se rendent chaque année en
france pour évidemment on ne prenons pas
du tout cette annonce à la légère et
nous essayons d'avoir des informations
très précises y at il pour l'heure la
municipalité de pékin reconnaît juste
avoir demandé à ces voyagistes d'inciter
les touristes chinois à veiller à leur
sécurité
ce nouvel épisode indique en tout cas
que pékin maintient la pression sur la
france
peut-être parce que nicolas sarkozy n'a
pas encore confirmé sa présence à la
cérémonie d'ouverture des jeux
olympiques retour en force avec une
expérience originale 250 enfants d'une
école de strasbourg ont ainsi réussi à
tenir dix jours sans écran autrement dit
à remplacer toutes ces heures passées
devant la télévision par des balades à
vélo de lecture ou encore des heures de
sommeil en plus un défi personnel qui a
gagné tout le quartier
on écoute ce soir les premières
réactions avec christine beauce et
nicolas frehner chez la famille var où
on a ressorti les jeux de société les
jouets des enfants ont envahi le salon
et michel huit mois résister à la télé
et où jeux vidéo pendant 10 jours sans
problème
beaucoup passer de temps en famille
entre amis
en discutant et en partageant des jeux
qu'on peut jouer ensemble
une des clés du succès ces ateliers de
cuisine jardinage ou danse organisé
après l'école le mercredi par les
parents d'élèves notamment à des six ans
l'opération vraiment un grand
investissement de l'enfant et en
français pape ont pensé au départ quand
il a eu lui ai dit savez si cet enfant
ainsi on la pensait retrouver à 40
enfants à quoi sera différent enfin
sûrement beaucoup de plus de choses avec
les enfants dans les classes c'était
l'heure du bilan après dix jours
d'abstinence
maintenant les 10 jours sont terminées
mais par exemple est-ce que ce matin
vous êtes précipité sur la télé non
quand je me sens nuit j'ai craqué après
j'allume l'ordinateur et j'ai joué a
déjà 9 ans 10 sociétés mais sert
j'ai joué avec ma petite soeur et je
vais aussi avec mon petit frère au
pointu
j'ai disputé en famille oui j'ai
remarqué un changement effectivement au
niveau de la tension des enfants au
niveau des choses qu'ils avaient a
raconté donc des enfants reposer plus
attentif et plus présent aucun la banque
de plus de 90% de réussite pendant 10
les enfants vous l'a dit autrement à la
télévision la question société du jour
peut-on réviser son bac sur internet
justement le sait la petite horloge des
examens est en marche c'est la période
alors pas de stress prendre son temps
s'organiser à chacun a sa méthode et le
nouvel outil de révisions pour le bac
c'est donc internet une sorte de réflexe
maintenant pour toutes ces générations
alors comment ça marche réponse nabila
taboury et olivier ponthus ce lors des
révisions a sonné pour l'eau rare un
petit clic
bonjour secondes ça a pu préparer ton
texte et c'est madame la nier sa prof
qui apparaît laura est dans sa chambre
anne fleur manier dans son salon entre
elles un écran d'ordinateur et un
entraînement à l'oral de français qui
peut commencer
j'ai retenu que tu connaissais bien les
figures de style sauf que j'ai pas
réussi à suivre sur les figures de style
laure a découvert ce site de soutien
scolaire il ya quelques mois un problème
de maths à résoudre une dissertation
préparer quel que soit le moment de la
journée
un prof est là pour l'aider à raison de
8 euros les 20 minutes est différent
prof objet de prendre toujours la même
donc ça mais d'avoir à avoir différentes
différents opinion de moi et donc ça me
ça me fait vraiment un tableau de mes
défauts et améliorer derrière l'écran ne
peut pas être prof qui veut la plupart
sont enseignants lycéens étudiants ou
même consultant comme une fleur leur
capacité à enseigner sont évalués mais
pas seulement c'est dû montrer ma pièce
d'identité mon casier judiciaire j'ai dû
montrer les justificatifs de mes
diplômes j'ai eu plusieurs étapes ça
colle mon père fred et des entretiens
avant d'être embauchée dans un lycée
à quelques semaines du bac les sites de
révision fleuri sur internet la plupart
sont payants ont petit tester ses
connaissances télécharger des fiches ou
encore combler ses lacunes sur des
forums pourtant aucun label de qualité
n'existe encore lille ou sur l'anxiété
les candidats l'anxiété des familles et
on sait très bien que sur ce marché là
il ya il ya des gens honnêtes mais il ya
aussi des gens qui font de l'argent
comme toujours sur internet la prudence
est de mise
ainsi payant n'est pas forcément
synonyme de qualité en cas de doute ne
pas hésiter à consulter son enseignant
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle selon
les dernières enquêtes le nombre de
fumeurs baisse chez les plus jeunes sauf
à paris d'ailleurs on est en revanche
encore très loin d'un rejet massif de la
cigarette et pour aider ceux qui ont
fait le choix de stopper ou de ralentir
la consommation quelques lycées mettre
en place de vrais projets
d'accompagnement
c'est le cas dans l'hérault à pézenas
une méthode de relaxation suivi par léo
lamberton et françoise mazou
j'en ai conscience des bras
sans allonger le nom de votre corps ces
jeunes filles sont en pleine séance de
sevrage tabagique une fois par semaine
elle se retrouve à l'infirmerie du lycée
pour tenter d'arrêter de fumer et la
relaxation est une aide précieuse en
prend conscience le système respiratoire
et de l'air qui enfante permet de
respirer et qui n'est pas encombré par
la merci à m
le lycée agricole de pézenas dans
l'hérault expérimente depuis deux mois
une méthode de sevrage tabagique mise au
point par le centre de lutte contre le
cancer discussions relaxation mesure du
taux de carbone dans les poumons
visiblement ça marche fait j'étais un
paquet par jour et maintenant je tombais
race 4 voire trois si le raid par jour
que j'ai commencer par diminuer petit à
petit éliminer les cigarettes qui était
inutile pour moi et à la fin
complètement arrêté au total 18 lycées
du sud de la france propose ainsi une
aide au sevrage tabagique mais il est
difficile de convaincre les jeunes
d'arrêter de fumer à pézenas sur 65
lycéens fumeurs seuls quatre ont été
volontaires j'ai bien fumer je continue
à fumer et malgré les lisent que ça à
des risques on verra plus tard
je peux forcément envie d'arrêter
pourquoi parce que j'ai pas de volonté
ici on espère que grâce à l'émulation
d'autres élèves seront tentés si
aujourd'hui en france la moitié des
jeunes de 18 ans fument
seuls 5 % arrivent pas arrêter le sport
sans cigarette maintenant et on commence
par le tennis avec une sorte de jour de
fête à roland garros tout simplement car
il n'a pas plus aujourd'hui sur le
terrain du bon et du moins bon côté
tricolore à un zéro pointé pour les
filles et quelques espoirs côté garçons
notamment grâce à paul henri mathieu sur
place julien benneteau et chloé cormery
journée strip tease à roland garros le
parisien michaël llodra se qualifie pour
les huitièmes de finale et il offre au
court central une joie très
déshabiller contre l'italien bolleli
spécialiste de la terre battue
draps applique sa tactique favorite il
se ruait au filet où il est capable de
voler réflexe impressionnante brillant
joueur de double le français s'affirme
enfin en simple à 28 ans il s'impose en
trois sets
pilier de l'équipe de france de coupe
davis
il est aussi un vrai boute en train qui
fête sa victoire à coups de bouteille
d'eau dans les vestiges avait demandé il
ya le show centrale on savait que ça
allait être dur mais quand on donne tout
ce qu'on a à prendre quand on joue à la
maison donc c'était dur lui aussi enlève
le haut pour fêter sa place en huitièmes
de finale le français jérémy chardy 21
ans en 48e joueur mondial dominant en
trois sets le russe tursunov tête de
série son arme principale
un service surpuissant et dire qu'il
bénéficie d'une invitation des
organisateurs du saut modeste classement
il y à quelques minutes le français paul
henri mathieu s'est lui aussi qualifié
pour les huitièmes de finale en dominant
en quatre sets l'argentin schwank sa
collaboration avec max wilander ancien
vainqueur de roland garros semble porter
ses fruits
c'est l'euphorie dans le clan français
florent serra se qualifie pour le
troisième tour
même bonheur pour julien benneteau qui
suit en bas de l'écran
auteur du plus beau coup de la journée
contre le colombien falla qu'on appelle
ça une volée amortie rétro voilà qui
fait oublier la bérézina du côté des
françaises elles vont toutes été
éliminées d'un mot de basket américain
tony parker ne remportera pas soutenu le
titre en nba
son équipe des spurs de san antonio se
patine
hier soir face aux lakers de los angeles
lors de la finale de la conférence ouest
prenons maintenant la direction de rome
où la villa médicis va prochainement
changer de directeur un poste on le sait
très convoité la villa médicis c'est un
lieu historique et culturel où depuis
louis xiv des artistes viennent
perfectionner leur discipline en italie
reportage de nos correspondants philippe
visseyrias et karine guillaumin il a été
choisi parmi des dizaines de candidats
pendant six mois vincent delecroix
écrivain sera l'un des pensionnaires de
la villa médicis vu bienvenue dans ce
palais du xvième siècle et son domaine
de sept hectares au coeur de rome ici la
france propriétaire des lieux
accueillent depuis deux siècles une
partie de son élite artistique comme les
18 autres pensionnaires de la villa
vincent delecroix va toucher un salaire
de 2500 euros par mois et sera logé dans
un pavillon
il pourra écrire à son rythme sans
obligation de résultat
on entre comme dans un club de vacances
c'est pas c'est pas un club de vacances
quoi nous fait vraiment
faut être à la hauteur à la hauteur
d'une légende qui a vu passer dans ses
murs berlioz debussy ou ingres
aujourd'hui encore la villa médicis se
veut le point de rencontre entre
différentes formes d'art peinture arts
graphiques musique design offrir à ces
artistes comme véronique ellena
photographe un cadre de travail unique
c'est une année entre parenthèses ou
l'est la galère s arrête pour un enfant
est ce assez
c'est exceptionnel dans la vie d'un
artiste
pourtant depuis quelques semaines dans
la presse française la villa médicis et
critiques certains politiques et hauts
fonctionnaires l'a10 coûteuse moribonde
coupé du monde et de la création
richard peduzzi son directeur en fin de
mandat se défend c'est criminel attaque
et des mini 6 pour moi c'est des gens
qui ne savent pas le rôle qui ne
connaissent pas le rôle de la mine 12h06
ce sont des gens inconscients ils
attaquent leur pape leur propre
patrimoine
loin des polémiques vincent delecroix
l'écrivain savoure sa première journée
dans la ville éternelle
ici il s'est promis d'écrire un roman
rod s'offre à lui
source inépuisable d'inspiration et on
continue avec du théâtre à paris cette
fois au théâtre de la colline
la pièce s'intitule par dessus bord elle
nous plonge avec humour dans le monde de
l'entreprise son évolution son langage
et vous allez le voir cette technique de
marketing reportage sophie joue et
frédéric capron
6h30 comédiens un orchestre de jazz et
guesh patti pour raconter l'histoire
d'une entreprise de papier toilette qui
va se faire manger tout cru par la
concurrence internationale
et si cette histoire sont tellement
justes et tellement humaine c'est que
l'auteur michel vinaver vert était dans
les années 60 tenez vous bien le pdg de
gillette france
notre seul pdj dramaturge témoin
privilégié des bouleversements de
l'entreprise
ce n'est pas vraiment une satire c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt un compte rendu de
comment ça fonctionne ce système
économique dans laquelle nous sommes
avec sa cruauté
tout y passe
le grotesque des réunions de
brainstorming le charabia des
responsables du marketing d'achats et
celles d'entre vous qui n'entreront pas
dans la danse et bien ils resteront sur
le quai ce n'est pas une menace c'est
une constatation
je pense que le capitalisme de ce moment
là avait quelque chose du topic
alors qu'aujourd'hui il a quelque chose
anxiogène c'est quand même
cela parle aussi de l'affolement des
petits employés de base devant une
machine qui s'emballe du tour millions
de la société de consommation par dessus
bord une pièce insolente écrite par un
cadre qui n'a pas peur de bousculer ses
propres patrons
j'ai pas eu peur d'être viré parce que
je le souhaitais d'une certaine façon il
fallait il fallait que je que je dégage
mais au milieu point de licenciement et
michel dinh à vera poursuivi sa double
vie tdg et écrivain voilà par dessus
bord c'est jusqu'au 15 juin au théâtre
de la colline à paris avant de refermer
journal je vous rappelle l'une des
principales informations c'est la
découverte de cet enfant en vendée ce
matin alors que son corps flotter dans
l'eau du lac d'apremont un enfant qui
est toujours ce soir dans un état grave
mais dont on ne connaît toujours pas
l'identité
aucune disparition n'a été signalée pour
le moment dans la région et ce sur la
gendarmerie lance un appel à témoins
voilà pour l'actualité de ce vendredi
merci d'être fidèle à l'info sur france
2 demain je vous retrouve dès 13h pour
le journal et le magazine 13h15 dans un
instant la météo isabelle martinez suivi
du point route valérie maurice puis
votre série sur le fil passé une très
belle soirée et à demain j'espère
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr